à 74 ans Jean-Claude Ruquier a décidé de
ne pas se représenter aux élections
sénatoriales dans son département du Lot
la succession est ouverte pour prendre
la suite de celui qui dirige un groupe
historique du Sénat celui des radicaux
sur les rangs de candidats d'un côté
Rafael daubet 46 ans maire de Martel
représente la branche Macron compatible
des radicaux plus vieux partie de France
désormais divisée en plusieurs tendances
aujourd'hui je me présente devant vous
donc pour ce mandat sénatorial
en me disant je vais encore assez jeune
pour avoir de l'énergie je vais essayer
un peu de quai de casser les codes et
puis officiellement Jean-Claude Ruquier
ne soutient personne mais Rafael daubet
veut croire que sa proximité avec celui
qui fut maire de la même commune que lui
fera la différence
je le crois je le crois très sincèrement
je le crois je vais pas demander parce
que je pense que ça peut être compliqué
pour lui vis-à-vis aussi des autres
candidats
et puis je veux pas être étiqueté comme
le fils spirituel de Jean-Claude Roquier
j'essaie de faire aussi mon propre
chemin mais j'ai aucun doute sur son
soutien
Geneviève lasfargue elle représente le
PRG partir radicale de gauche l'autre
branche des radicaux
actuel suppléante de Jean-Claude Roquier
elle aussi revendique le soutien du
sénateur sortant
oui je pense qu'il nous soutient
oui parce que je suis légitime qui me
soutiennent
deux candidats pour une seule place si
les radicaux ne veulent pas perdre leur
siège dans le lot il faudra sans doute
que l'un des deux appelle à voter pour
l'autre second tour et ce n'est pas
encore gagné vous êtes prêtes à appeler
à voter pour nous bah écoutez tout
d'abord
d'abord je me présente on verra le 24
septembre et on verra le deuxième tour
d'accord mais vous ne suivez pas
dans le Lot l'autre siège de sénateur
revient historiquement aux parties
socialiste et pour l'occuper un candidat
fait figure de favoris c'est le maire de
Cahors
et dans le même temps le Sénat me paraît
être une chambre du coup ben qui prend
une place intéressante parce que d'abord
on travaille au delà de son étiquette
politique ce proche de Carole Delga a un
atout de taille la Présidence de
l'Association des mers du Lot un réseau
précieux dans cette élection indirecte
ou 95% des grands électeurs sont des
élus municipaux
Jean-Marc vaisus fort pourrait bien
s'imposer dès le premier tour comme
président de l'association des illuses
et l'Occitanie forcément que les
discours que je porte qui est
extrêmement sincère qui est pas qu'un
discours électoraliste vraiment il me
donne un petit avantage peut-être par
rapport aux autres concurrents mais
encore une fois le jeu est ouvert et
il faut rendre le bon choix je n'en
doute pas autre candidate investie par
le Parti socialiste la sénatrice
sortante en gel Preville que nous
n'avons pas pu rencontrer pour des
raisons de santé elle a dû interrompre
la fin de sa campagne et reste bien
candidate à sa propre succession mais
une troisième candidature à gauche
pourrait lui compliquer la tâche celle
d'Anne n'apporterait
n'a pas l'investiture socialiste le
parti la suspendu après les dernières
législatives où elle s'est présentée
comme suppléante face aux candidats
officiel de la nuque désormais elle part
sans le soutien d'un parti mais pas sans
expérience du Sénat car elle a aussi été
la collaboratrice de la sénatrice
socialiste sortant en gel Préville
contre qui elle se présente aujourd'hui
personne ne se présente contre personne
ou alors tout le monde se présente
contre tout le monde on est neuf
candidats comme sur une piste
d'athlétisme très concrètement sur le
terrain ce n'est pas ce qui intéresse
les grands électeurs les questions de
parties les questions politiques ce qui
les intéressent très concrètement c'est
ce que chacun peut apporter dans le Lot
le scrutin sénatorial se joue en effet
moins sur l'appartenance à un parti que
sur la personnalité des candidats et
leurs capacités à convaincre des élus
majoritairement sans étiquette cette
année l'élection s'annonce
particulièrement ouverte entre radicaux
et socialistes et on regarde la liste de
l'ensemble des candidats dans le Lot je
vous rappelle que deux sièges de
sénateurs sont à pourvoir dans ce
département c'est donc une élection qui
va se jouer au scrutin majoritaire et
non à la proportionnelle au scrutin de
liste et l'élection sénatoriale on se le
redit ce sera dimanche
[Musique]